uh gordon you uh will potentially if
you're healthy face andre galvao in the
adcc coming up super fight
uh who is andre galvao for people who
don't know can you tell the story of
your beef with
uh the the emotional interaction with
the man yeah so uh andre is uh
he's considered the greatest adcc
competitor of all time uh multiple time
black belt world champion uh winningest
adcc champion every has six six gold
medals and uh i've been trying to
compete against him
pretty much forever like since i got my
black belt in 2016 i've been trying to
get matches with him uh he was in the
first ebi that i did and he ended up
pulling out and that i've been trying to
get matches with him
and uh he would always say no and give
one reason or another
and then
after the last adcc i was like hey andre
said he was retiring after this after
this uh
this competition so if he wants to
retire you know he's he's the greatest
adcc competitor of all time and
i think it's great but if he wants to
compete and that's great i was like
super nice and then he started like
posting like passive aggressive
instagram
uh
uh captions and uh then we started going
back and forth on the internet and there
was like one point where i saw him in
person when he
acknowledged he's like i understand like
what you're doing like we're going to
pump this fight up and he was like
totally on board but then there must
have been something that happened where
like it changed from like him like going
along with it to being like actually
pissed
and then uh there was that one night at
flow where i went to go shake his hand
and he he flipped me off and then he
fought me backstage and started to try
to fight me and then i smacked him and
then he didn't want to fight anymore and
then we've been going back he's actually
blocked me on instagram now so he will
he just won't engage no one from atos
will engage now but
it's gonna be interesting how he shows
up if he can keep it under control or
not do you think how do you explain that
level of emotion is this fear of losing
your throne is it
is it just a human being like with
cyborg just
just becoming emotionally unstable it
might just be me i just have a way to
get and get under people's skin it's
just i don't know uh he's he's
he was he was cool for a while and then
i just i don't know it just
everyone gets like this they're all so
emotional by the time they actually step
up to compete that it's pretty easy to
read them they're either so emotional
that they want to actually come forward
and and beat me like uh like tim spriggs
is a perfect example at abcc i posted
like uh
on my story on instagram like 10 minutes
before our match i said like what i'm
going to do to tim spriggs is going to
be criminal and he's like a very stally
guy and he came he saw that and then he
came out and actually tried to fight me
like he came and actually engaged my
guard and i ended up submitting him so
it either has that effect or it has the
effect where they know i've talked so
much leading up to the match that
they're so afraid to lose that they just
get super stally and they move away so
it either has one effect where they come
forward and they wanna they wanna beat
me beat me or they wanna just they're so
afraid of getting submitted that they
know if they engage they're super cagey
and they just back away and don't really
do anything
do you think this match happens
there's a lot of variables one i have to
see how my stomach is and two if i'm
actually going to show up and compete my
stomach's healthy i doubt that andre
will actually show up to compete i've
been trying to compete against him for
six years and he hasn't done it so
there's no reason to think he would now